bonjour La voix est Libre en direct sur
France 3 tous les samedis avec
aujourd'hui quatre voix pour une
question faut-il casser les seuils
sociaux pour créer de l'emploi il a-t-il
d'autres recettes assurance chômage
apprentissage ou travail du dimanche
avec nous sur ce plateau Pierre-Antoine
KNE président du MF de Bourgogne bonjour
bonjour Sandrine Mouret secrétaire de la
CGT de côedor bonjour à vous bonjour
marieclaude jarot maire UMP de Montceau
et présidente des maires de saéloir
bonjour marieclaude jar bonjour et Fadil
catabi conseillère régional PS juste
rentrée de l'Assemblée des Régions de
France à Toulouse bonjour bonjour et
merci et vous pouvez intervenir chez
vous vous l'avez déjà fait sur notre
site internet sur le réseau Twitter avec
les hashtag F3 Bourgogne et lvel
Bourgogne alors ce jeudi patronat
syndicat ont commencé à négocier sur le
dialogue social avec un chapitre
consacré à la réforme des seuils sociaux
les seuils qui organisent la
représentation tion syndicale et sociale
et qui déclenche aussi pour les
entreprises un certain nombre
d'obligations le gouvernement souhaite
un assouplissement il souhaite je cite
que des verrous soient levés le ministre
du Travail François repsamen nous l'a
dit il y a de semaines sur ce plateau
même on l'écoute pour lancer cette
discussion ce que je souhaite c'est que
on passe dans notre pays mais c'est très
difficile d'un affichage c'est-à-dire de
de droits qui sont affichés et au droits
réels je vais donner un exemple simple
vous savez il doit y avoir un délégué du
personnel dans les entreprises de plus
de 10 euh 66 % des entreprises de entre
10 et 20 n'ont pas de délégué du
personnelou parce que oui parce que
peut-être on trouve pas parce que et et
ça des fois je dis aux organisation
syndicale c'est pas normal c'est pas
normal voyez vous vous satisfaisez de ça
mais moi je m'en satisfais pas vous
savez il y a beaucoup de il y a des
lourdeurs dans les seuils le seuil de 50
il est d'une lourdeur absolue et donc on
peut simplifier et en même temps on peut
améliorer la représentation il s'agit
pas de supprimer
ésentn contéor ce j'ai dem contre il a
des réunions qui sont multiples et même
les syndicalises le reconnaissent donc
j'espère qu'ils vont aboutir à lisser à
avancer à simplifier ces seils Sandrine
mour il est pas excessif le ministre du
Travail
finalementer améliorer le dialogue
social dans l'entreprise pour
qu'effectivement les salariés so
entendus ça c'est une bonne chose le
problème c'est quebat se focalise sur
ces seuils sociaux c'est-à-dire le
moment où on déclenche la
représentativité des salariés le moment
où les salariés sont représentés dans
leur entreprise pour faire valoir leur
revendication mais aussi parce que nous
nous souhaiterions que les salariés
soient consulter sur la marge de
l'entreprise sur la stratégie de
l'entreprise et pour défendre leurs
droits c'est ça l'enjeu et l'enjeu ce
que demande le le gouvernement c'est
effectivement la qualité et l'efficacité
du dialogue social ou pas se focaliser
sur les seus sociaux il envisage aussi
peut-être quelques remontée de seuil ou
quelques fusion d'institution aussi ça
c'est lui qui l'envisage mais je
remarque quand même je remarque quand
même ça ça ça sera la négociation qui
qui qu'il verra mais je remarque quand
même que puisque nous prenons
l'Allemagne puisque nous prenons
l'Allemagne toujours en référence en
terme de développement économique
notamment dans l'industrie les comités
d'entreprise se mett en place à partir
de 5 salariés avec des pouvoirs des
instances représentatives du personn
beaucoup plus importante qu'en France
beaucoup plus importante puisque le
comité d'entreprise doit être consulté
et il doit y avoir un accord sur toute
décision économique qui pourrait
impacter les salariés je remarque aussi
que comme l'a dit Monsieur repsamen
effectivement 40 % des entreprises de
moins de 50 n'ont pas de représentation
du personnel alors ce n'est pas ça qui
ve il parlait il parlait des 10 je crois
oui mais en fait quand on prend les
seuils ça fait 40 % des entreprises de
moins de 50 qui n'ont pas d'irp voit
bien que ce n'est pas ça qui entrave le
développement des entreprises parce que
c'est ça c'est ça fond du problème le
MDEF lui c'est un cou qu'on va poser à
Pierre-Antoine KNE vous vous souhaitez
ces seuils les faire sauter alors déjà
je voudrais dire que c'est pas parce
qu'il y a pas de de délégué du personnel
dans les entreprises de plus de 10
salariés qu' n'y a pas de dialogue avec
les salariés bien évidemment toute
entreprise normalement et sereinement
gérée par un chef d'entreprise le chef
d'entreprise instaure un dialogue avec
ses salariés quel que soit le niveau
d'ailleurs encadrement ou ou ou autres
salariés donc déjà je pense que il faut
pas euh stigmatiser une situation
qui qui supposerait qu'il n'y ait aucun
dialogue avec les les salariés dans les
entreprises alors ensuite je vous
parliez de de l'exemple de l'Allemagne
c'est un bon exemple puisque on a un un
un pays qui est là à des salariés qui
sont quasiment tous syndiqués le vrai
problème de la France c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on a des syndicats qui
sont malheureusement pas suffisamment
représentatif et qui ne dépasse pas je
crois 7 % des salariés donc c'est très
très peu effectivement c'est sans doute
une des causes qui fait que les les les
différentes représentations du personnel
ne sont pas assumées dans un certain
nombre d'entreprises alors pour ces
seuils aujourd'hui il il constittu
aujourd'hui davantage des des comment
dire des contraintes financières et
réglementair terrible pour les
entreprises je vous donne un exemple une
entreprise qui passe de de 8 à 10
salariés parce que il y a une petite
étape à 9 salariés elle va déjà voir ses
taxes augmenté de l'ordre de 10000 € par
an hein la taxe transport par exemple
qu'elle ne prait pas en dessous de 9F
salariés et bien là elle va payer par
exemple 5000 € de taxe transport si on
prend l'exemple de Dijon hein euh par
ailleurs il y a un formalisme qui est
extrêmement lourd dans la la mise en
œuvre de ces de ces délégués du
personnel il faut savoir que si le
processus électoral n'est pas respecté
pour une question de forme par exemple
il y a des sanctions pénales prévues par
la loi et des amendes automatiques dans
un certain nombre de cas donc on est
dans un système très contraignant pour
les chefs d'entreprises qui est donc
anxiogène et les chefs d'entreprise
n'ont donc pas envie sauf projet
particulier de dépasser 10 ou 50
salariés c'est une évidence on va y
venir et en une question à Fadila catabi
vous en tant conseiller régional le
rapport avec les entreprises ça fait
partie des compétences du Conseil
régional aussi est-ce que ce qu'on ce
qui est dit par le medf c'est quelque
chose que vous ressentez est-ce que ce
dialogue social il a besoin parce que
c'est une de vos casquettes aussi d'être
d'être aidé d'être modifié il est ancien
les lois sur le travail elle date des
années 80 pour parti quelle est votre
position là-dessus écoutez en région
bourgonne en tous les cas euh moi je
suis très attaché au dialogue social et
on a pu l'exercer d'ailleurs en région
Bourgogne puisque nous avons créé un
outil qui est le conseil en évolution
professionnelle et c'était bien sûr à la
demande des partenaires sociaux pour
effectivement sécuriser les parcours
d'ailleurs le coner évolution
professionnelle a depuis été repris au
niveau national puisqu'il y a eu une loi
là-dessus donc bien sûr je crois
beaucoup au au débat démocratique au
sein de des entreprises ceci dit le
gouvernement effectivement répond à
l'appel avant tout d'ailleurs du meddeef
répond à l'appel du meddeef mais en
aucun cas effectivement c'est pour
j'allais dire faire en sorte qu'il n'y
ait pas de débat social au sein des
entreprises c'est comment on peut
moderniser le dialogue social au sein de
l'entreprise comment on peut améliorer
les choses pour faire en sorte
effectivement que l'entreprise puisse
retrouver des marges de manœuvre
d'ailleurs je voudrais dire que le
dialogue social contribue aussi à la
compétitivité je m'adresse ici à
Monsieur à Monsieur Kern contribue
également à la compétitivité des
entreprises parce que des salariés qui
travaillent non pas dans la défiance
mais dans la confiance des salariés bien
formés bien informés contribu ce sont
des salariés qui sont bien à leur poste
de travail et donc sont plus performant
et donc plus compétitif Marie Claude
jarot j'ai relevé un chiffre qui est que
il y aurait en France d'après l'INC deux
fois et demi plus d'entreprises de 49
salariés que de 50 salariés est-ce que
le maire de Monceau que vous êtes le
ressent dans sa sa vie de maire dans son
rapport aux entreprises des entreprises
qui finalement seraient je mets
conditionnel bloqué par les
seuils je ne crois pas que les
entreprises soient bloquées par les
seuils je crois plutôt que cette cette
conversation que nous avons aujourd'hui
sur la représentation syndicale et
sociale et plus
particulièrement ce pourquoi vous nous
avez convié sur les les seuils
sociaux c'est un peu l'arbre qui qui
cache la forêt parce que que les
entreprises comme je lesai vis dans ma
ville elles ont des
préoccupations liées à leur
développement économique je reprends le
le propos de Madame Mouret de tout à
l'heure je crois que
si l'activité économique était plus
forte si les les personnes trouvaient un
emploi et bien si ça permettrait
d'associer vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure madame d'associer
très simplement les salariés à la
stratégie de l'entreprise parce que
cette ce climat
anxiogène sur les difficultés
économiques des petites entreprises je
répondrai à la question que vous m'avez
posé quand même fait que tout tout se
cristallise tout tout ce se rigidifie
mais est-ce qu'il vous en parl les
patrons oui voilà c'est ça le sens il
m'en parle mais il ne me parle pas de
seuils sociaux il ne me parle pas de de
de dialog social ils me disent
simplement notre carnet de commande est
vide et ça c'est un problème et hélas on
ne peut pas embaucher et là et les
salariés que je reçois parce que je
reçois énormément de personnes qui qui
cherchent un emploi les
salariier ne me parle pas non plus de
dialogue il me parle de trouver un
emploi et si les choses allaient mieux
d'un point de vue économique et bien ça
détendrait un peu ce dialogue social
parce que dans les entreprises de moins
de 10 dans les entre
le dialogue il existe je je ne crois pas
qu'il faille faire un procès ni au chef
d'entreprise ni au salariés le dialogue
doit exister si dans les entreprises de
100 le dialogue n'existe pas c'est qu'il
y a un problème d'homme et de femme
aussi bien aussi bien employeur que
salariés vous allez tous bien sûr avoir
la parole je relance la discussion avec
un chiffre le Medef annonce 50 à 100000
emplois sous 3 ans avec la modification
des seuils sandR
vous allez SR tous c'est comme il un
million d'emplois c'est c'est pareil
puisque c'est contredit par l'INC
effectivement l'INC a fait une étude
relativisant très à la baisse les
l'effet sur l'emploi par contre pour
pour rebondir oui mais pour rebondir et
ce qu'on a entendu au niveau du
gouvernement les salariés aiment leur
entreprise et d'ailleurs on peut
remarquer que ce sont les premiers à la
défendre quand elle est menacée ce sont
les premiers des fois à interpeller leur
direction lorsqu'il remarquent un un
manque un manque d'investissement
lorsqu'il porte des revendications en
terme d'investissement de conditions de
travail en terme de nouveau marché c'est
souvent le comité de d'entreprise qui
font ces propositions là eux ils aiment
leur entreprise regardez l'entreprise
Parker qui a fermé la Dijon depuis des
années le comité d'entreprise
interpellit le groupe sur le manque
d'investissement sur ce site résultat
alors que ce groupe touché du cice et du
crédit impô recherche il n'y avait rien
dans les tiroirs C été accaparé sans
rien au bout par contre les salariés eux
avaient des projets de développement
d'investissement ils n'ont jamais été
entendus voilà pourquoi nous on dit que
les salariés quel que soit la taille de
l'entreprise doivent pouvoir être
consultés et avoir voix au chapitre sur
la stratégie de l'entreprise
pardonnez-moi je vous coupe mais est-ce
que en même temps vous entendez ce qui
peut être dit par le patronat qui est de
dire on peut comprendre qu'un patron qui
a 47 salariés qui a du mal à joindre les
debouts qui a du mal à remplir son
carnet de commande se disent moi je je
non je veux pas être obligé d'avancer
mes mises en paye je veux pas être
obligé de créer ça je veux pas avoir des
salariés qui certains jour ne vont pas
travailler parce qu'ils vont s'occuper
de de ça est-ce que c'est quelque chose
que vous comprenez ou pas je l'entends
mais dire que les entreprises vont mal
parce qu'ils ont des délégués du
personnel ou un comité d'entreprise non
et ça c'est d'ailleurs Ctait pas le sens
de ma phrase cétait est-ce que vous
comprenez qu'on puisse ne pas vouloir
passer le seuil à cause de ça je ne
pense pas je pense réellement que si les
entreprises ne peuvent pas se développer
c'est notamment effectivement parce que
les carnets de commande sont vides un
manque d'investissement un manque de
pouvoir d'achat moi je suis désolé les
petites entreprises il y a un manque de
pouvoir d'achat notoire un manque de
carnet de commande du un effectivement
un une baisse de pouvoir d'achat de
l'ensemble des ménages notamment pour
tout ce qui est pour les petites
entreprises pour les artisans mais en
plus effectivement il y a des erreurs
stratégique phénoménal en terme
d'investissement de recherche sur des
nouveaux produits à forte valeur ajoutée
que ne font pas les entreprises
Pier-Antoine carne 5 100000 emplois
Sandrine Mouret dit c'est pas vrai euh
c'est pas moi c'est
lin dit que Linc dit pas vrai pardon moi
moi je suis en désaccord avec ce que je
viens d'entendre pour une bonne raison
c'est que le le principal problème des
entreprises françaises est un problème
de compétitivité le carnet de commande
c'est pas un cadeau qui est fait par je
ne sais qui je ne sais je ne sais à quel
moment le carnet de commande c'est
quelque chose qu'on va conquérir parce
que on est bien placé en prix avec des
services corrects voilà c'est ça la
réalité et la réalité de notre pays
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on pays le plus
fiscalisé avec le taux de prélèvement
obligatoire le plus important d'Europe
et les contraintes en matière de droit
du travail notamment à travers ces
seuils mais pas qu'à travers ces seuils
les plus importants d'Europe donc la
réalité c'est qu'aujourd'hui si nous
sommes en mauvaise posture sur le plan
économique nous devons à l'ensemble de
ces contraintes réglementaires et on
pourra parler du droit du travail plus
largement s'il le faut et donc oublier C
ces carnets de commande carnet de
commande c'est quand on est bien placé
en prix qu'on les a mais je oui je
voulais dire par rapport au carnet de
command demande en tout cas on sait que
l'emploi est intimement lié à la
croissance s'il n'y a pas de croissance
il y a pas d'emploi c'est clair mais la
croissance il faut aussi aller la
chercher et le gouvernement a
effectivement mis tout un tas de
d'outils je pense notamment au cice hein
au crédit
emploi et compétitivité à la banque
publique d'investissement donc il a mis
effectivement une série d'outils sur la
table qui contribuent effectivement à
donner un bol d'air aux entreprise pour
pouvoir faire en sorte que le coût du
travail soit moindre ça c'est la réalité
et pour en revenir au seuil rentre de
Toulouse et donc à une table ronde il y
avait une chef d'entreprise qui avait
repris donc l'entreprise de son père qui
a développé l'entreprise et qui avait
dit bah justement moi je suis à 49
salariés aujourd'hui donc je me pose la
question faut-il embaucher ou pas alors
que vraiment j'ai besoin de trois
salariés donc décidez-vous vite sauf que
le débat est mis sur la table et c'est
les partenaires ce sont aux partenaires
sociaux effectivement de s'emparer de la
question avant de légiférer et donc je
me pose la question et ensuite elle a
dit elle a répondu elle a fait la
réponse elle-même en disant de tout
toujours est-il que je pourrais de toute
façon créer je suis en train de
réfléchir pour créer une autre structure
donc il y a toujours quand même des
possibilités pour contourner la loi je
veux dire par rapport à cela mais qui
contourneront aussi d'une certaine
manière la représentation syndicale du
coup d'une certaine manière il y a déjà
eu de rapidement parce on on a
l'impression qu'effectivement les seuils
seraient couprè alors que déjà depuis
quelques temps il y a effectivement des
largesses des souplesses qui ont été
donné sur bah déjà le nombre de salariés
hein il faut savoir que tous les
contrats
ne sont pas comptabilisés les apprentis
ne sont pas comptabilisés les temps
partiels au prorata du temps passé dans
l'entreprise donc déjà il y a certaine
largesse il y a la loi sécurisation de
l'emploi qui a été voté il y a pas
longtemps qui instaure un délai de 90
jours au lieu de 45 jours il y a aussi
également puisque vous parliez des
cotisations la loi de modernisation de
l'économie en 2008 qui avait déjà
différé 3 ans l'assujétissement à
plusieurs cotisation sociale et
également hein on voit que le
franchissement de ces seuils ils doivent
se faire sur 12 mois consécutifs ou non
donc du coup il y a certaines largesse
et moi je je suis en train de regarder
et et quel résultat sur l'emploi elles
sont pas d'IER il y a des des souplesses
et il y a pas de résultat sur l'emploi
donc le le le débat que l'on met
maintenant nous ferait croire que ça
créerait de l'emploi et déjà les
largesses les souplesses données sur les
seuils n'en nonont pas créé Mar claud
jarot moi je crois je je viens de le
dire aussi les seuils euh ne sont pas un
frein à l'emploi ce qui est un frein à
l'emploi fondamentalement c'est la
croissance c'est le potentiel
d'investissement en même temps faire
baisser le coup du travail c'est une
façon d'essayer de redonner de la
croissance alors le coût du travail il
le coût du travail il est composé de
plusieurs de plusieurs éléments on on en
reparlera si vous permettez mais ce que
je veux ce que je veux vous dire aussi
c'est que moi dans mon bureau je reçois
dans la tout mon saau est fait de petite
entreprises de TPE voire de toutes
petites entreprises je reçoit à la fois
des des patrons et des salariés qui
viennent
ensemble pour parler des difficultés de
leurs entreprises donc on voit bien que
certes il y a les seuils mais il y a
aussi l'instauration de ce vrai dialogue
social et je crois ce que que les
salariés aspirent à être associés à la
stratégie de leur entreprise ça c'est un
élément fort et ils sont associés à la à
la à la stratégie de l' entreprise que
ça instore la confiance et non pas la
défiance et que ensemble les les
employeurs et les salariés travaill à
l'investissement dans leur entreprise
est-ce que c'est pas un c'est pas un
monde idéal que vous soyiez en train de
nous décrire là par quand on suit
l'actualité c'est pas exactement ce
qu'on voit parce que la représentation
pardonnez-moi mais la représentation
elle a a aussi été mise en place pour
protéger les salariés dans un certain
nombre de cas les
CHSCT droit d'alerte tout c chos par que
on est par de de dialogue mais il y a
aussi une notion de barrière à des
conflits ou de de règles du jeu dans des
des situations conflictuelles je vais
vous donner un exemple très précis
auquel je pensais quand je j'ai pris la
parole l'entreprise
Eon avec la centrale Luce vous savez que
l'entreprise va fermer à moins que un
une entreprise reprenne l'activité ce
dont je doute bon qui est-ce qui a porté
le projet de réhabilitation de cette
entreprise de ce territoire la CGT la
CGT qui a porté une étude sur la
réhabilitation du site et qui a
travailler avec
Eon voilà un
exemple difficile parce qu'il y a 60
suppressions d'emploi mais la CGT en
collaboration avec son employeur Eon qui
est un employeur qui éloigné un peu du
site apporter ce dialogue social pour
trouver des solutions des solutions de
réhabilitation des solutions
d'investissement des solutions pour les
salariés donc les seuils je je redis ce
que je disais tout à l'heure les seuils
sont un peu l'arbre qui cache la forêt
il faut instaurer cette confiance cette
confiance et je suis d'accord avec ce
qu'a dit Madame madame Mouret
l'INC ne valide bien le fait que les
seuils la suppression des seuils ne CR
pas ne créera pas dans je suis d'accord
qu'il faut toujours se méfier quand même
des chiffres ça me rappelle par rapport
au seuil rappelez-vous sur la la TVA
concernant la restauration on nous avait
dit effectivement il faut la baisser je
ne dis pas effectivement qu'il faut la
remonter pas du tout mais en tous les
cas que ça allait créer 100000 150000
emplois que ça allait améliorer le
pouvoir d'achat des salariés ainsi que
celui des consommateurs mais c'était
surtout en terme d'emploi on nous a
agité effectivement le drapeau de
l'emploi en disant que ça allait créer
plus de 100000 emplois aujourd'hui je
veux dire les résultats sont très très
tigé donc méfions-nous quand même des
chiffres on sent dans ce que vous dites
des sortes de transversalité par moment
moi j'ai envie de vous poser une
question sur le moment auquel on est en
ce moment dans la vie du pays dans la
vie sociale et politique on voit qu'à
gauche il y a de grands débats sur
est-ce que le gouvernement va pas trop
vers le patronat est-ce qu'on est à un
moment important de réforme où justement
on met sur la table des choses qu'on
nait pas mis sur la table publquement
j'allais dire jusqu'à maintenant et
est-ce que si ces choses-là réussissent
c'est important pour le pays est-ce que
vous pensez que non c'est de mauvais
débat moi je vais commencer par
Pierre-Antoine carne en vous demandant
si d'un côté le gouvernement fait un pas
vers le patronat on lui reproche assez
est-ce que le patronat fait un pas lui
vers le gouvernement parce qu'on a pas
forcément l'impression que c'est
réciproque moi moi j'ai le sentiment
qu'il y a un pas intelligent alors je
sais pas si c'est vers le patronnat ou
plutôt vers le développement économique
la réalité des chiffres parce que vous
vous méfiez tous des chiffres enfin il y
a des chiffres qui sont éloquent c'est
ceux du chômage aujourd'hui à fait donc
je pense que c'est surtout ceuxlà qu'il
faut regarder et ça fait 30 ans qu'on
écoute pas les chefs d'entreprise donc
ça serait peut-être bien maintenant des
écouter parce que ce sont eux qui créent
l'emploi et personne d'autre autrement
dit euh non mais c'est quand même une
réalité vous avez un pays qui s'appelle
la Suisse qui est à 200 km de Dijon où
il y a un taux de chômage inférieur à 3
% le code du travail fait 80 pages et
euh il y a une liberté pour
l'entrepreneur pour développer ses
entreprises qui peut lui permettre de de
de s'adapter en terme d'effectif et
cetera mais c'est pas grave là-bas parce
qu'on retrouve un emploi tout de suite
et c'est ça qui est l'équilibre vertueux
vers lequel on doit tendre et non pas
construire des lignes maginaux
permanentes bétonner le droit du travail
bétonner les seuils qui empêchent les
chefs d'entreprise d'avoir la liberté
d'entreprendre la liberté d'adapter
l'activité et l'emploi dans l'entreprise
parce que c'est ça qui globalement crée
de l'emploi dans le Pay alors je vous
rajoute un mot contrepartie B
contrepartie c'est l'emploi c'est
l'emploi naturel qui vient avec cela
ouais on ne peut pas mettre
mécaniquement en face de de de chaque
mesure on peut mettre des des ambitions
de développement mais naturellement on
peut pas faire un contrat comme on fera
un contrat en droit commercial en disant
voilà pas une dimension d'attitude
est-ce qu'il y a pas une dimension
d'attitude c'est-à-dire estce que de
volonté de la part du patronat est-ce
qu'elle existe cette volonté d'essayer
aussi de pour le coup de peut-être pas
s'arrêter au seuil mais de créer les
emplois puisque en face il y a le cice
il y a tout ça le rôle d'un chef
d'entreprise je vais peut-être vous
surprendre c'est pas de créer de
l'emploi tout de suite c'est de
développer un projet alors ce projet
naturellement se concrétise par de
l'emploi mais première chose c'est de
développer un projet alors ensuite s'il
peut développer ce projet de de manière
satisfaisante dans un écosystème
favorable ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui dans notre pays ça
s'améliore mais ça n'est pas le cas
encore aujourd'hui dans notre pays alors
à ce moment-là effectivement
naturellement par voie de conséquence
l'emploi est créé voilà c'est ça ce ce
vers quoi nous devons tendre monsieur
c'est ce qu'a voulu faire le
gouvernement avec c'est vraiment la
mesure la mesure phare j'étais moi
personnellement à la conférence sociale
j'ai vu quand même le président du MDE
France applaudir dè deains donc donc
c'est aussi là vraiment un outil très
pertinent alors évidemment aujourd'hui
sur le chômage on ne voit pas encore les
résultats mais moi je suis très très
positive parce que ça va venir sauf que
les projets effectivement mettent du
temps pour pouvoir aboutir et cetera je
veux dire je suis désolé on va pas la
situation s'est dégradée suite à la
crise depuis quand même 2000 2007 2008
surtout et on ne va pas effectivement
créer de l'emploi d'un claquement de
doigt donc il faut mettre des bons
outils pertinents pour effectivement de
nouveau créer de la richesse pour les
entreprises créer de la richesse sur not
territoire ça c'est clair là je suis
tout à fait tout à fait d'accord en PR
parce qu'elle
trp mais termin je me je me moquais
c'est par contre par rapport au seuil je
suis d'accord il faut peut-être
simplifier il faut simplifier il y a 23
seuils et cetera peut-être que là c'est
pas une question de seuil mais peut-être
plutôt simplifier et voir effectivement
comment on peut améliorer le coût de la
représentativitéation don on voit pas
beaucoup
tomber non mais je crois que vraiment il
y a un travail ici de fondil 2ne
comprend rien voil
peutêtreén un député côedorien qui est
coprésident de mais quand on parle des
ses c'est surtout le 10 et 50 qui
revient systématiquement qui est mis sur
la
tableour oui c'est on est à une
charnière je sais pas si on a une
charnière mais je crois qu'effectivement
puisqu'on parlait du développement des
entreprises je rappelle quand même que
dans les entreprises il y a des salariés
et que Monsieur KNE vous pourrez bien
avoir tous les investisseurs du monde
tous les fonds de pension le meilleur
bâtiment les plus belles machines les
plus beaux les plus belles machines
outil plus beaux ordinateurs les plus
belles matières premières si vous n'avez
pas de dents de salariés d'ouvriers
d'ingénieurs de techniciens de
commerciaux vous ne sortirez pas 1 € de
votre entreprise le chiffre d'affaires
et les bénéfices qui en sortent se font
grâce au travail des salariés c'est pour
ça que nous on insiste pour que les
salariés puissent avoir voix au chapitre
dans le développement et la stratégie de
cette entreprise après sur les moyens
que prend le gouvernement le cice la CGT
n'est pas opposée à aider les
entreprises bien bien bien évidemment
des entreprises qui ont un projet sur
des matériaux novateurs sur
l'investissement seulement il y a pas de
contrôle le cice je vous prends un
exemple je vous prends un exemple une
boîte de Longvie
elle elle a eu des aides publ je les
note 2011 84 2011 323000 € d' he sur sur
deux dispositifs c'est tout hein 2013
714000 € d'ê publi puisqu'il y a le cice
qui s'est rajouté dedans résultat
résultat et bien Mo- 23 emplois sur la
même période et
500000 €
d'investissement il est allé où cet
argent non je donne un exemple alors je
vous en donne un autre carrefourtin non
mais le problème c'est que pour dire
monsieur Kern pour dire que
C les a au reises doivent être
conditionné et contrôlé par les salar le
comité d'entreprise les salariés doivent
pouvoir vérifier que l'argent public qui
est donné à cette entreprise bénéficie
bien à l'investissement à l'emploi à
l'amélioration des conditions que
c'est pas déjà les collectivités qui
devrai le contrôler aussi bien évidment
mais je parle au nom des salariés bien
évid mariear c'est un moment charnière
ou pas il nous reste une minute avant
midi je je crois que ce qu'il faut qu'on
décrète est ce que essaie de faire le
gouvernement sans doute c'est une
mobilisation générale à la fois des élus
des entrepreneurs des salariés pour
l'emploi ça c'est un c'est c'est quelque
chose de fondamental c'est-à-dire que
les seuils enfin tous les outils l'outil
contrat de travail il faut que l'on soit
tous réunir
par j'aime bien la politique ça aurait
pas d vous qui ou maire de droite est-ce
que ça aurait pas dû être fait
précédemment sous le quinena précédent
on attendait plutôt ça d'un gouvernement
de
droite écoutez moi je suis maire d'une
ville de 20000 habitants j'ai été élu
présidente de l'Association des maires
de
saéloire candidat législa vous êtes
régional donc les législatives c'est
c'est ancien je je crois que nous avons
et je le ressens au niveau des maires de
sonellois nous avons à à nous mobiliser
tous au service de l'emploi parce que
faut que je vous coupe mar est midi et
on va se faire discuter mais on reprend